o videogame é uma droga
essa é a principal reclamação e hoje um
pai uma mãe tem com relação às
tecnologias digitais
tudo isso porque os videogames são hoje
a principal fonte de lazer e
entretenimento
a maioria das crianças que nós temos em
casa
hoje em dia o excesso de uso do
videogame pode trazer vários problemas
ele pode trazer má alimentação e
irritabilidade dores na coluna fadiga
visual privação do sono e pode levar até
ao vício
além disso os jogos têm um conteúdo
normalmente muito machista muita
violência causa um certo isolamento da
criança em relação ao seu meio e muitas
vezes não só para crianças e
adolescentes mas também para idosos pode
levar a uma dependência dessa tecnologia
como o pai me preocupo com os meus
filhos eu tenho duas crianças e às vezes
eu convido eles pra ir para uma
apresentação de teatro
aí pra dar uma volta de bicicleta e
jogar um futebol com os colegas e às
vezes preferem ficar na frente do
computador jogando enfim usando esse
tempo na frente do computador
mas o nem tudo pode ser tão ruim
há sete anos atrás eu tive um acidente
de moto e esse acidente eu machuquei o
braço ao ombro e teve que fazer uma
cirurgia
essa cirurgia após ela ter terminado eu
tive que fazer fisioterapia
talvez vocês que já tenham feito
fisioterapia tenha descoberto que nem eu
que fisioterapia uma atividade
extremamente perigosa extremamente chato
e cansativa mas que funciona então eu
pensei será que não dá para associar
todo aquele tempo aquele aquela moça
aquela atenção e motivação que se tem
com jogos para a fisioterapia será que
não está não dá pra fazer jogos que tony
a fisioterapia mais interessante até
porque eu reconheço os meus filhos que
os jogos podem trazer alguns benefícios
afinal a diferença entre o remédio eo
veneno está na dose
nós temos que controlar a dose então a
dose é fundamental para nós podemos
transformar uma atividade uma tecnologia
que talvez não seja tão boa e tirar a
parte boa dessa tecnologia e os jogos
hoje são reconhecidos por ter algumas
vantagens
os videogames têm algumas alguns
aspectos que são importantes
eles trazem raciocínio está zen por
exemplo meu filho aprendeu inglês
melhorou em inglês dele assistindo os
jogos socialização porque ele chega no
colégio ele vai conversar com os colegas
nós jogamos aquilo e no final de semana
que ser feita
acontece uma certa socialização também é
reconhecida a amplitude da visão
espacial que se ganha
os jogos e principalmente os jogos
os videogames casa em uma grande
motivação para as pessoas de modo geral
então por causa disso nós começamos a
fazer jogos né que trabalhavam o
movimento
esses jogos nós conseguimos através de
uma webcam barata através de um
computador convencional desenvolver
jogos que reconheciam os movimentos das
pessoas e através desses movimentos das
pessoas poderiam interagir com o
computador sem precisar segurar nenhum
dispositivo e o computador então
apresentava as tarefas para essa pessoa
na forma de um jogo
com isso nós desenvolvemos inicialmente
um jogo para pacientes de avc derrame
cerebral
justamente nesse jogo nós temos gotinhas
caindo na tela ea pessoa que tem alguma
deficiência de um dos lados porque o avc
causa uma deficiência em um dos lados do
corpo ela tinha que interagir com as
gotinhas virtuais que vinham caindo mas
essas gotinhas elas apareciam em
posições determinadas pelo
fisioterapeuta controlados pelo jogo mas
determinadas pelo fisioterapeuta
então a pessoa se vivia dentro do jogo e
interagindo com as gotinhas virtuais e
ela começava a fazer movimentos que ela
precisava para sua fisioterapia mas às
vezes sem perceber
depois pegamos esse jogo e fizemos
algumas adaptação umas coisas pequenas
com relação às entidades gráficas
voltadas para a criança se no caso
nós aplicamos a crianças com síndrome de
down
nessa adaptação além dos bonequinhos o
tempo do jogo a pontuação do jogo né
nós conseguimos fazer com que o jogo
estimulasse na criança com síndrome de
down não só acorda
na ação motora mas a atenção a
concentração que eram aspectos
fundamentais para a criança com síndrome
de down a sua própria concepção ou seja
sua percepção de partes do corpo e do
planejamento de movimento que ela faz e
apresentamos para os fisioterapeutas que
trabalhavam com crianças com síndrome de
down
depois nós pegamos esse jogo também
começamos a fazer extensões
melhoramentos no jogo a ponto de nós
termos depois uma a uma extensão no
sentido de valorizar e fazer a criança e
interagir com os aspectos do letramento
que é a princípio a a parte inicial da
aprendizagem da leitura e da escrita
esse jogo diferente do anterior onde as
gotinhas caíam agora nós temos as letras
que estão aparecendo no na tela do
computador ea criança mais uma vez tem
que fazer um certo planejamento motor
para poder alcançar a letra correta que
representa referência aqui
o jogo está apresentando para ela isso
então estimula a identificação da forma
da letra e estimula também todo o seu
planejamento da sua coordenação motora
mas recentemente nós tivemos uma pequena
alteração nesse jogo e ele agora está
tentando aspectos cognitivos
então nós apresentamos desafios para a
criança para ela poder associar de
maneira indireta
não de maneira direta ela tem que
raciocinar o que tem nesse jogo que do
que eu tenho que associar aquele 1 com
aquela outra figura que aparece ali
naquele ambiente é para em que a criança
está dentro do jogo sem usar nenhum
dispositivo
também já fizemos jogos muito parecido
com jogos que as crianças estão
acostumadas hoje em dia de jogos de
exploração onde a gente trata da
temática da dengue é um jogo em que a
criança tem que explorar os espaços têm
que verificar onde que estamos possíveis
focos do mosquito da dengue e dentro do
caminho ela vai encontrar informações
vai aprender sobre a doença vai aprender
sobre a prevenção à doença da dengue e
também fizemos um jogo onde nós
estávamos dependentes químicos que estão
dentro de comunidades terapêuticas sendo
atendidos e acolhidos em comunidade que
executa o programa terapêutico chamado
12 passos que o programa mais comum mais
conhecido para a recuperação e
dependentes químicos
esses jogos
eles têm pelo menos duas características
que gostaria de enfatizar com vocês
primeiro a nossa preocupação enquanto
pesquisadores de avaliarmos
concretamente os resultados desses jogos
então por exemplo no caso de pacientes
de derrame cerebral nós conseguimos
constatar uma um aumento no número de
movimentos que o paciente aprende mesmo
sem perceber
conseguimos aumentar em 74%
a número de crianças que tiveram nota
acima de 7
em testes sobre o conhecimento da dengue
e conseguimos fazer com que crianças com
síndrome de down que usasse os nossos
jogos por cinco semanas tivesse um ganho
de desenvolvimento motor equivalente a
16 meses
além disso outro aspecto que eu gostaria
de enfatizar com vocês é que estes jogos
foram construídos com a participação
direta dos estudantes lado do
departamento de computação sem a ajuda
dos alunos
esses jogos não teriam acontecido mas
fundamentalmente com a ajuda de
fisioterapeutas psicólogos terapeutas
ocupacionais geriatras uma série de
profissionais sem os quais a
convergência dos nossos caminhos esses
jogos não teriam tido esses resultados
fantásticos então videogame uma droga na
dose certa
ele pode ser muito bom mas os remédios
das drogas não só para o tratamento ele
pode ser usado também para a prevenção e
à prevenção nós fizemos além passar aqui
os fizemos a prevenção em algumas
situações por exemplo no caso da
prevenção do uso da dengue
desculpa com a prevenção do uso de
drogas psicoativas
também fizemos um jogo porque os jogos
não são pra ir para crianças jogos
também podem ser para idosos
a gente quando vai ficando idoso a gente
vai perdendo um pouco da nossa condição
de equilíbrio e vai perdendo um pouco a
nossa mobilidade
então trabalhar a mobilidade ea condição
de equilíbrio de idosos é uma condição
que ajuda a evitar em queda e evitar a
hospitalização e evitar inclusive mortes
esse jogo nós desenvolvemos onde o idoso
se vê naquele túnel tem alguns desafios
ele tem que fazer alguns movimentos e
com essas pequenos movimentos que ele se
vê obrigado a fazer
ele começa a reaprender a sua condição
de equilíbrio
os jogos então eles servem para a
prevenção servem para o diagnóstico e os
jogos são coisa séria porque são drogas
eu acredito que no futuro muito próximo
nós vamos ter profissionais devidamente
capacitados prescrevendo videogames você
vai chegar com o ortopedista você vai
chegar com um psicopedagogo você vai
chegar com seu endocrinologista
reclamando de alguma condição alguma
dificuldade ele vai prescrever pra você
com videogame